thanks for joining us America we are
glad you're here
you can follow me on twitter at dave
ramsey
on facebook.com slash david adams ii and
we answer actually some of the questions
on twitter Chloe says what do you think
about living in a mobile home for a year
to save up for a down payment on a house
wouldn't be a problem out if you're
renting it I wouldn't buy a mobile home
mobile homes go down in value it's the
only thing you own that you live in that
goes down in value even if you buy dirt
under it that goes up in value more than
it goes down in value so it appears you
didn't lose money you lost money you buy
a $50,000 mobile home in a few years
it's a ten thousand dollar mobile home
you buy a fifty thousand dollar house in
a few years it's a hundred thousand
dollar house this home you just don't
want mean cars go down and buy you
mobile homes go down in value it's a car
you sleep in I mean that's what you're
dealing with so if you want to rent one
that's fine I've had a few people over
the years that have called me that went
and bought a $5,000 mobile home put it
on a piece of ground paid cash for it
knowing that the five thousand dollar
mobile homes could be worth three
thousand dollars but they're gonna lose
a couple grand and that's their form of
rent while they save up money and pay
cash to build a house on that land
people have done stuff like that that's
fine
but this idea you're gonna buy 75 80
$100,000 $50,000 mobile home and call
that a good long-term plan no it's not a
good long-term plan it goes down in
value it's simple right a buddy of mine
owns a huge mobile home operation and
he's always giving me a hard time would
you quit saying that Dave and I said
well they won't it quits being true I
quit saying it we've got some that go up
in value don't went when when I see that
as an across-the-board thing yeah now I
will tell you this manufactured housing
is what the hell is call it there in one
way the other there's all kinds of
manufactured housing sometimes that
means mobile home sometimes that means
the wall system for built a factory they
stood them up and it basically looks
like a stick built house and so it's
treated by the purchasing public
like a traditional home whatever you're
buying I don't care what words you used
to describe it the question you ask
yourself is when I walk up in front of
it do I say mobile home or do I say
house
if you walk it up in front of it you say
house ugly house pretty house but it's a
house right then then that's gonna go up
in value and a mobile home with the
wheels off sitting on a concrete
foundation that looks all permanent
still looks and feels like a mobile home
when you walk into it and as long as
people think it was that it's not a
house it's not gonna go up in value
because that's how the market perceives
it and that's what you've got to look at
so whatever you're putting into that
you're throwing that money away so back
to you Chloe what do you think about
living in a mobile home for a year to
save for a down payment if you're doing
that $5,000 mobile home thing won't pay
cash for it and live there for a year
while I save up some money that's fine
because you're just giving up you know
some of the $5,000 not turning not owing
50,000 on something that's now worth 30
where you get upside down in the thing
or if you're talking about renting
something and that's what you want to do
sure
whatever wherever you want to rent I
don't care it cheap rent as cheap as you
can rent does that means you can save
more for your down payment hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]